.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Okay. Äh ...
Wie heisst du?
- Ich heisse Besijan.
Wie alt bist du?
- 16.
Woher kommst du?
Ich komme aus Ex-Jugoslawien,
aus Kosovo.
Und warum bist du hier?
Tja, ich weiss nicht.
Vielleicht, weil meine Eltern
hier zu arbeiten begonnen haben.
Dann bin ich hier aufgewachsen.
Jetzt ist es meine zweite Heimat.
Und?
Ja, jetzt sind wir wieder hier.
Vor 20 Jahren
sah ich dich zum ersten Mal.
Ich drehte einen Dokumentarfilm über
deine Schulklasse im Zürcher Kreis 4.
Du bist mir mit deinem wilden Charme
und deiner offenen Art aufgefallen.
Doch sah ich in deinen Augen
auch Unsicherheit.
Eine Verletzlichkeit
und einen inneren Kampf.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
du seist auf der Suche
nach Zugehörigkeit gewesen
und hattest damit zu kämpfen,
dass du dich in der eigenen Heimat
fremd fühltest - in der Schweiz.
Nach dem Filmprojekt
verlor ich den Kontakt zu dir.
Du hattest damals schon
einen Weg eingeschlagen,
der eine schwierige Zukunft
vermuten liess.
Ich finde es nicht so geil,
Drogen zu nehmen.
Aber sie verkaufen, ist lustig.
Du kriegst viel Kohle.
Zwölf Jahre waren vergangen,
bis wir uns wiedersahen.
Du hattest dich inzwischen für
eine kriminelle Karriere entschieden.
Wegen bewaffneten Raubes bekamst du
knapp fünf Jahre Gefängnis.
Ich wurde auf dich aufmerksam,
weil ich diverse Zeitungsartikel
über dich las.
Man nannte dich
den "geläuterten Rapper".
Du hast dich verändert
und an dir gearbeitet.
Du hast bereut, eine Therapie
und eine Ausbildung zum Koch gemacht.
Du hast im Schreiben und Rappen
ein Werkzeug gefunden,
um zu verarbeiten -
ein Mittel zur Reflexion.
Du hast dich
für gefährdete Jugendliche eingesetzt
und viele Seminare
und Workshops gegeben.
Sie haben dir zugehört,
und du konntest etwas bewirken.
Du wurdest
eine Art Sozialarbeiter der Strasse.
Während deiner Zeit im Gefängnis
nahm das Schweizer Stimmvolk
die Ausschaffungsinitiative an.
Jetzt bist du zwar draussen,
aber nicht wirklich frei.
Du könntest jeden Moment
ausgeschafft werden -
in dein Herkunftsland Kosovo.
Und das, obwohl du in der Schweiz
lebst, seit du ein Baby bist.
Guten Tag zusammen!
Hallo, Besi! Geht's gut?
- Ja.
Hallo, Bruder!
- Hallo. Alles klar?
Ja, ja.
Mürsel, wie geht's dir?
- Sehr gut, und dir?
Ja, ja. Gefällt dir die Schweiz?
- Die Schweiz ist cool, Mann!
Ja?
Und, Besko, was hast du vor?
Was willst du
mit deiner Karriere machen?
Ich muss schauen.
Aber Musik
werde ich sicher weiterhin machen.
Mal schauen,
was das Bundesgericht entscheidet.
Und wann ist es so weit?
- Das kann man nicht sagen.
Aber bis dann
bist du noch in der Schweiz?
Ja, so lange
bin ich noch in der Schweiz.
Du bereust sicher,
was du gemacht hast, oder?
Ja?
- Ja. Ich kann viel geben.
Du siehst das auch
bei den Jugendlichen, die kommen.
Das ist ...
Das ist meine Region hier und ...
Man sollte integrierten Menschen
wie uns eine Chance geben.
Unsere Eltern hatten es schwer.
Die könnten uns nicht wie ...
Also meine Mutter und mein Vater
sind keine Ärzte oder Juristen,
die mir helfen könnten.
Bei uns ist es ziemlich schwer.
Ich denke, solchen Menschen wie uns
sollte man eine zweite Chance geben.
Und ich denke,
Besko hat es verdient.
Er geht einen guten Weg.
Ja, ich danke dir.
# Grüezi mitenand,
ich bekenn mich schuldig.
# Han erkennt,
dass ich selber schuld bin.
# Mini Tate
sind durch nüt z'entschuldige.
# Sueche nöd nach Usrede,
ich bi dr Schuldige.
# Wenn ich ehrlich bin,
isch's e bitzli luschtig gsi.
# Was mer nöd so macht
i sinere Jugendzit.
# Für en hoche Pris -
han foif Jahr übercho.
# Vier bini scho drin
und eis sitzi immer no.
# Trotz Vorwarnige
hetts mich nie interessiert.
# Drum verstahn ich,
we mer jetzt d'Konsequänze zieht.
# Aber Hand ufs Herz:
Isch es nöd eso,
# dass sich Mensche
doch no ändere chönd?
# Eui Frag isch:
Wieso? Wieso erscht jetzt?
# Mengisch
bruchts halt en lange Wäg,
# bis mer sin Pfad setzt,
lueged, ich hans umgsetzt.
# Ich bin es Vorbild worde.
# Tuusigi vo Jugendlichi,
wo mini Gschicht verfolged.
# Das hett mir niemert gschänkt,
hans mir hart erkämpft.
# Jede Mensch, wo jetzt denkt,
dass ich d'Hoffnig versenk,
# hett nöd erkennt,
dass ich min Kampf niemals ufgib.
# Egal, was passiert,
ich bins ihne schuldig.
# Mine Fans, de Jungs, de Familie.
Ich vermisse diesen Ort hier.
Aber ich habe auch Probleme,
hierherzukommen.
Jedes Mal erwarte ich meine Mutter,
dass sie mich draussen holt
oder mich zusammenstaucht,
weil ich zwei,
drei Wochen nicht mehr hier war.
Ja. Es ist eben schwierig.
Aber eben: Ich bin hier
immer herzlich willkommen,
egal ob von Sabri und seiner Familie
oder den anderen Nachbarn.
Sie freuen sich immer wieder,
mich hier zu sehen.
Es ist halt schwierig, denn wir
reden immer über dieselben Themen -
ob es um die Ausschaffung geht
oder den Tod der Mutter.
Und ... ja.
Es ist schwierig.
Hörst du seine Musik?
- Sicher.
Eigentlich fühle ich es ...
Ich weiss nicht,
ich fühle es einfach mit.
Ich bekomme Gänsehaut,
wenn Besijan rappt.
Ich kann das so richtig mitfühlen,
was er durchlebt hat.
Und ... ja, eigentlich ...
Ich kann nicht mehr dazu sagen.
Sein Rap gefällt mir einfach sehr.
Auch von den Rhymes her,
die er bringt.
Einfach alles, was er rappt.
Es gefällt mir sehr.
Die Jugend von heute.
Ich habe es hier. Schau mal!
Das ist auch so was: Ich als einer,
der nicht in die Schweiz gehört ...
Und das, bevor das alles passierte.
Ich habe dieses Tattoo seit acht,
neun Jahren: Zürich Kreis 4.
Kennst du Beskos Situation?
- Sicher.
Was sagst du dazu?
Es ist scheisse.
Was ist Integration?
Morgens aufstehen, um zu arbeiten?
Das ist
die Integration eines Menschen?
Das müssen die Menschen tun, das
ist, wenn man etwas erreichen will.
Fehler gehören zum Leben.
Und ich finde ...
Auch ein Integrierter macht Fehler.
Also besser gesagt, ein Schweizer.
Nur, weil ich Fehler gemacht habe,
heisst das nicht,
dass ich in der Schweiz
nicht integriert bin.
Was ist überhaupt
Integration in der Schweiz?
Man weiss ja gar nie,
wann man Schweizer ist oder nicht.
Es gibt so viele verschiedene Fälle.
Was ich gemacht habe,
ist schon gross, aber ...
Es hat auch damit zu tun ...
Du kanntest meine Lage.
Ich spielte früher sehr viel.
Ja, ja, das ist klar.
Sehr viel gespielt -
das war mein Problem.
Mir ging es eigentlich sehr gut -
legal.
Gut, ein bisschen illegal,
aber nicht so,
dass es gleich
eine Gefängnisstrafe gäbe.
Dann fing ich selber zu spielen an,
und dann war es ...
Nicht mal das war der Faktor,
sondern dass ich Schulden hatte.
Eben: Jeder kennt meine Geschichte.
Und wenn die Kredithaie dir sagen:
"Ich will das Geld nicht mehr",
hast du ein Problem.
Solange sie dir drohen
und den Zins anheben, weisst du,
dass du noch etwas Zeit hast.
Aber wenn sie dir sagen,
sie wollen das Geld nicht mehr,
hast du ein Problem.
Und bevor ich noch meine Familie
in Probleme brachte,
griff ich halt sozusagen
nach der falschen Lösung.
Gegen Schluss wurde es gefährlich,
auch in meiner Situation,
denn ich ging mit der Einstellung
auf die Strasse:
"Wenn es so ist, weint besser
ihre Mutter statt meine."
Das hätte in die Hose gehen können.
Es klingt dumm,
aber es musste so kommen.
Ich bin froh,
wurde ich damals verhaftet.
Schau hier! Die Vier.
# Ta-ta-ta-ta.
- Oh!
Nein!
* Lachen und Jubel *
Es ist kalt hier unten.
* Lachen *
* Korkenknallen, Jubel *
Sie sagen ganz bewusst Ja
zum Partner und zur Partnerin.
D.h., Sie erklären sich bereit,
sich gegenseitig so anzunehmen,
wie Sie sind -
mit all den negativen Seiten,
aber natürlich und v.a.
wegen der durchaus positiven Seiten,
sagen Sie Ja zueinander.
Pythagoras ... Kennen Sie ihn?
Den kennen wir.
Den kennt jeder.
Aber der gute Pythagoras ...
... hat nicht nur Formeln ...
- Ich liebe dich trotzdem.
Man muss ihn nicht unbedingt kennen.
Es ist nicht so wichtig.
Nein, wirklich nicht.
- Spielt er Poker?
Haha.
- Dann kenne ich ihn nicht.
Er hat mathematische Formeln
aufgestellt. Auch nicht schlecht.
Wollen Sie mit Besijan Kacorraj
die Ehe schliessen?
Ja, ich will.
Nun richte ich die Frage an Sie,
Besijan Kacorraj:
Wollen Sie die Ehe schliessen?
Ja, ich will.
Da Sie beide
meine Frage bejaht haben,
ist Ihre Ehe durch die
beidseitige Zustimmung geschlossen.
Herzliche Gratulation!
Das ist
der internationale Eheschein,
auch als Beweis Ihrer
heutigen Heirat hier in Zürich.
V.a. auch für Sie in Serbien,
dass die Heirat nachgetragen wird.
Mhm.
- Sie sind nicht Doppelbürgerin?
Nein.
- Sie sind zu 100 % Schweizerin?
Ja.
- Dann brauchen Sie keinen.
Ich bin auch zu 100 % Schweizer. Ich
habe nur nie einen Pass beantragt.
Das kann sich noch ändern, oder?
- Nein, ich überlege es mir noch.
Tut es weh?
- Nein, nein.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Ringe.
- Jetzt haben Sie sie. Alles klar.
Frau Kacorraj,
ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute
für die gemeinsame Zukunft
und für die Geburt.
Wann kommt es zur Welt?
- Im Februar.
Ah, dann am 15.
Dann habe ich auch Geburtstag.
Frau Schweizer, danke Ihnen!
- Alles Gute!
Du hast Jacky kennengelernt.
Ihr habt euch für
ein gemeinsames Leben entschieden.
Bald kommt euer Sohn zur Welt.
Das, was du nie hattest,
was du dir schon immer
gewünscht hast, ist zum Greifen nahe:
eine eigene Familie.
1985 kamst du in die Schweiz.
Du warst sechs Monate alt.
Deine Mutter arbeitete als Kranken-
schwester und zugleich als Kellnerin.
Sie hatte fast keine Zeit für dich.
So landetest du im zweiten Lebensjahr
plötzlich im Zürcher Oberland.
Die ersten Erinnerungen,
die ich überhaupt habe,
sind diejenigen
an meine Pflegefamilie in Uster.
Das war eine Schweizer Familie.
Ich bekam als Kind dort
sehr viel Liebe.
Ähm ...
Disziplin, Anstand ...
... Danke und Bitte sagen ...
Ich glaube, ich war ...
... bis sieben Jahre
ein richtiger Oberschweizer.
Wahrscheinlich sehr viel
mehr Schweizer als viele Schweizer.
Mein erster Schulthek ...
Er war viereckig mit ...
... diesen Pferdehaaren,
die man früher hatte.
Also eigentlich sehr teure Theks.
Und in Uster waren alle Schweizer.
Ich glaube,
wir hatten alle so einen.
Das änderte sich,
als ich in den Kreis 4 zog.
Das wurde mir
ein bisschen zum Verhängnis,
weil ich
irgendwie der Schweizer war.
Ähm ... Ich habe mich
immer als Schweizer gefühlt.
Na ja, Schweizer und ...
Schau, ich bin ein Shwippi.
Bis zum siebten Lebensjahr
lebte ich bei dieser Pflegefamilie.
Auch wenn der Kontakt
nicht mehr da ist,
sind sie
für mich immer noch ...
... emotional
sehr starke Bezugspersonen.
Und ...
... was am Ganzen wehtut ...
Irgendwann hätte ich zu meiner
leiblichen Mutter ziehen sollen
oder müssen oder wie auch immer.
Für mich, meine Pflegefamilie
und auch meine Mutter war klar,
dass das nicht ewig andauert.
Was wehtat oder was heute noch
wehtut, ist die Art, wie ich ging.
Von heute auf morgen
und plötzlich ohne Kontakt.
Man erzählte mir
nur noch Schlechtes über sie.
Ich war mir sicher,
dass das alles nicht stimmte.
Ich fragte mich, warum sie mich
nicht mehr haben wollten.
Damals
kam mein Stiefvater ins Spiel.
Er war ein professioneller Dieb.
D.h., kriminell.
Ich erlebte das alles mit.
Wir hatten zu Hause Waffen,
Tresore, Bargeld, Drogen ...
Wir hatten zu Hause alles, was man
in der kriminellen Welt haben kann.
Was glaubst du, wenn du bei
der Pflegefamilie geblieben wärst?
Hast du dir das
schon mal vorgestellt?
Schau, ich wäre alles geworden
ausser kriminell.
Ich glaube,
das ist eine richtig faire Antwort.
Ich hätte alles werden können
ausser kriminell, glaube ich.
Diese Familie
hätte das niemals zugelassen.
* Jubel *
# Und sie säged,
ich söll zrug i mis Heimatland.
# Defür isch klar,
wo ich mini Heimat han.
# Und auch wenn ihr mich
us dr Schwiiz vertriebed,
# wird sie immer mini Heimat blibe.
# Und sie säged,
ich söll zrug i mis Heimatland.
# Defür isch klar,
wo ich mini Heimat han.
# Und au wenn dr Entscheid
noch i dr Luft liegt,
# blib ich schtarch,
wil ich nöd ufgib.
# Besko 28 Jahre lang.
- # I dr Schwiiz.
# Besko wurde ein Jahr alt.
# In die Windeln kackte er?
- # I dr Schwiiz.
# In Kindergarte isch er?
# Schule, Lehre machte er?
- # I dr Schwiiz.
# Verwandte und Familie leben alle?
# Freunde kennengelernt?
- # I dr Schwiiz.
# Wo spricht man seine Sprache?
# Die kriminellen Taten beging er?
- # I dr Schwiiz.
# Die Strafe sass er ab?
# Wo hat er sich geändert?
- # I dr Schwiiz.
# Er hat eine Chance verdient.
- # Ja, im Kosovo.
Zwei Jahre nach diesem Video
entschied das Bundesgericht,
dich auszuschaffen -
in dein Herkunftsland.
Und wieder wurde dir der Boden
unter den Füssen weggerissen.
Deine Heimat ist weg. Du bist
in einem Land, das du nicht kennst.
Deine Frau und du,
ihr habt euch getrennt.
Dein grösster Traum
einer eigenen Familie
und einem Leben in der Schweiz
ist geplatzt.
Du leidest darunter, v.a.
weil du dein Kind nicht sehen kannst.
Und trotzdem
wirkst du positiv und kämpferisch.
Du strahlst Zuversicht
und Selbstbewusstsein aus.
Ich hatte Angst.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Was erwartet mich?
Wie gehe ich damit um?
Ich dachte,
ich würde es nicht schaffen.
Trotzdem habe ich es geschafft.
Und ... Ja. Es ist cool!
Ich habe es geschafft.
Ich stehe auf eigenen Beinen.
Ich habe eine Wohnung und einen Job.
Ich habe ... äh ...
Ich habe einen guten Job.
Ich verdiene gut.
Ich habe kürzlich überlegt:
Ich sass länger als fünf Jahre.
Dann habe ich mir überlegt, was
der Unterschied zum Ausschaffen ist.
Jetzt geht es langsam.
Aber zu Beginn
war es fast schwerer als dort drin.
Dort drin hattest du deine Zelle,
bekamst deine Mahlzeiten
und hattest einen Job.
Du wusstest: Du bist in der Schweiz.
Dann kommst du hierhin:
kein Geld, kein Job, kein Nichts.
Es ist sehr hart.
Die richtige Bestrafung
fing mit der Ausschaffung an.
Alles,
was passiert, hat einen Grund.
Irgendwann zeigt er sich.
Ob er positiv oder negativ ist,
weiss ich nicht. Aber ...
It's a nice guy!
Ich wurde in vielen Interviews
gefragt, ob ich diese Sachen bereue.
Und ich sage es auch jetzt
nach unzähligen Jahren noch:
Ich bereue gar nichts. Ich würde
denselben Weg wieder gehen.
Er machte mich zu dem, der ich bin.
Das Einzige, was ich bereue ...
... ist eben der Schmerz,
den ich den Leuten zugefügt habe -
sei es den Opfern
oder eben meiner Familie.
Ich habe in der Zeit, in der ich
im Gefängnis die Therapie machte,
etwas gelernt, was ich
früher nicht kannte: Empathie.
Sich in den anderen zu versetzen
und zu versuchen zu fühlen,
wie er sich fühlte.
Hey, voll geil!
* Sie sprechen albanisch. *
Scheiss drauf!
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Oh, der tönt geil, Mann!
# Es git niemert, wo mer hilft.
# Der Schmerz isch da,
wil der Blitz mich trifft.
Wir nehmen den.
# Ich wott di nüme gseh,
bye-bye, bye-bye.
# Du bisch une dure, Babe, bye-bye.
# Ta-ra-ra-ra-ra, mm, mm, mm.
Nein.
Das wird gut. Wieso schreibe ich
immer solche Liebesscheisse?
Ich muss Gangsterrapper werden.
# Wieder dr gliche Traum mit dir,
wie jedi Nacht.
# Wieder dini Stimm,
wo mich us em Schlaf holt.
# Wieder di glichi Träne, wo ...
# Bye-bye,
ich wott dich nüme gseh, bye-bye.
# Du bisch jetzt une dure, Babe.
So in dem Sinn.
Tschau, Mann!
* Sie sprechen albanisch. *
Wie findest du es?
Er ist voll hinüber.
Er ist voll tschüss.
Ja, ja. Ja, ja.
# Nei, nei,
ich wott dich nüme gseh, hey.
# Bye-bye,
bisch jetzt une dure, Babe.
chunsch jetzt wieder zrug, hey.
* Besko spricht albanisch. *
# Bye-bye.
# Chunsch jetzt wieder zrug, hey,
bye-bye.
So! Herzlich willkommen.
Äh ...
Wir schreiben
im Moment den 12. September ...
Was haben wir heute?
Den 9. September.
Sorry schnell.
Wir haben heute
den 9. September 2017.
Vor zwei Wochen starteten wir hier
mit dem Aufbau des Callcenters,
das wir eröffnet hatten -
ich und zwei meiner Partner.
Und ... äh ...
Ich führe euch mal herum.
Dann seht ihr das.
Das ist la réception.
Da haben wir
unsere Administrationschefin
für diesen ganzen Bereich.
Da haben wir einen Chillingraum.
Und so was sehe ich gar nicht gerne.
Hm!
Die Mitarbeiter
hören am Montag von mir.
Das hier ist unser Inboundbereich.
Wir machen hier den Kundenservice
für verschiedene Firmen,
der sehr gut läuft.
Ich bin mir sicher:
Wir sind eines der schönsten,
wenn nicht das schönste Callcenter
in Kosovo.
Übrigens: meine Zusammenfassung.
Nein.
Das ist mein Büro.
Also vom sog. Chef.
Natürlich habe ich auch ein Headset.
Ich muss
ja auch telefonieren können.
Ja.
Alles in elf Monaten.
Man muss es nur schaffen wollen.
Dann schafft man es auch.
Elf Monate Kosovo.
Ich zeige euch
das Schönste dieser Firma.
Das ist der sog. Konferenzraum.
Dafür investierte ich
viel Zeit in die Planung.
Und es wurde ein Hammer.
Ja.
Eine neue Welt kennengelernt.
Besko, der Businessman.
Ich stehe wieder
unter starkem Druck, ja.
Ich habe damit eine
grosse Verantwortung übernommen.
Mein Gefühl sagt mir,
dass es erfolgreich sein wird.
Was ist dein Berufstraum?
- Hochbauzeichner.
Und warum Hochbauzeichner?
- Weil ich gerne zeichne.
Weil ich gerne etwas entwickle -
vielleicht.
Ja. Weil ich gerne plane.
Und wie sieht es damit aus?
Wie sieht es mit deiner Zukunft aus?
Also ich suche
immer noch eine Lehrstelle.
Aber ich habe etwas zu spät an-
gefangen. Viele sind schon vergeben.
Ich habe auch schon
eine Schnupperlehre gemacht.
Und ich hoffe, dass ich eine
Lehrstelle als Hochbauzeichner finde
und meine Lehre absolvieren kann.
Wie gehst du damit um,
dass du von der Schule weggehst
und ins Erwachsenenleben
umsteigen musst?
Ich weiss, dass es schwierig werden
wird. Aber man muss es lernen.
Es kommt.
Es kommt bei jedem Menschen so.
D.h.,
du bist jetzt schon 15 Monate hier?
Ja, schon.
15 verdammte Monate.
Eine verdammt lange Zeit.
Und es wird nachher auch wieder
verdammt schwierig, zurückzukommen.
Nach diesen zwölf Tagen.
Aber ... äh ...
Ich freue mich ja,
dass ich nächstes Jahr schon wieder
für zwei Wochen gehen kann.
Ist das sicher?
- Ja, das ist sicher.
Das erste Suspensionsvisum
wurde ja ...
Es wurde ja positiv beurteilt,
d.h., ich habe es bekommen.
D.h., dem zweiten
würde nichts im Weg stehen.
Dem dritten und vierten auch nicht.
Ja.
Das duftet total gut.
Ich will
einfach einen Job und eine Wohnung.
in der Nähe meines Sohnes sein.
Ich will
das Wochenende mit ihm verbringen.
Und so dachte ich mir: Lieber ...
Das klingt jetzt verdammt krass,
aber lieber bin ich
in der Schweiz eingeschlossen
und fühle mich
irgendwie zu Hause ...
... statt hier zu sein und ...
... jeden Tag kämpfen zu müssen.
Ich bin müde.
Ich bin müde. Ich bin müde.
Nur noch einmal schlafen.
Aber wie funktioniert das?
Wie kommst du an solche Kontakte?
Was für Kontakte?
- Dein jetziges Geschäftstreffen.
Alles läuft nur über Vitamin B.
Woher hast du das Vitamin B?
Gut,
durch meinen Partner in der Schweiz.
Woher hast du ihn?
Er ist ein Freund.
Du stellst aber dumme Fragen.
Wieso?
- "Woher hast du ihn?"
Er ist ein Freund von mir.
Ich hatte ja mal
in einem Callcenter gearbeitet
und so das Konzept gelernt.
Dann erzählte ich meinem Freund,
dass man mit einem Callcenter
eigentlich gute Geschäfte machen
und gut verdienen kann.
Dass es Potenzial hat.
Dann kam die Idee auf, eben ...
... so was zu eröffnen.
Und die finanziellen Mittel?
Woher hast du die?
Das ist Sponsoring.
Also Sponsoring ...
Er fand jemanden, der dieses Konzept
gut findet und es finanziert.
Und wer ist das?
- Ein Geschäftsmann aus der Schweiz.
Mit dem habe ich
eigentlich gar keinen Kontakt.
Okay. Den dürfen wir
jetzt auch nicht nennen?
Will er unbekannt bleiben?
Ja, den will ich auch nicht nennen.
- Wie?
Den will ich auch nicht nennen.
Warum nicht?
- Na ja, weil ich das nicht will.
Weil er das evtl. nicht will.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe ihn nie gefragt.
Und warum
hast du zu ihm keinen Kontakt?
Ich habe wenig Kontakt zu ihm.
Ich habe
mehr Kontakt zu meinem Partner,
mit dem wir
alles auf die Beine gestellt haben.
Den Investoren interessiert
das Geld, das er investiert hat,
und dann seine 30 %.
Zwei Parkplätze frei.
Das Erste, was ich machen werde,
wenn ich in die Schweiz zurückkehre,
ist ein Besuch bei McDonald's.
Besko, du zeigst denen ja,
dass es sich lohnt, zurückzukommen.
Na ja ...
Nein. Na ja ... Nein. Wieso lohnt es
sich? Wer sagt, dass es sich lohnt?
Geld ist nur Papier.
Du bist Vater.
Wie schwer ist es für dich,
von deiner Tochter weg zu sein?
Es lohnt sich nicht, glaub mir.
Ja, aber sieh mal ... Es ist
nicht leicht, so was aufzubauen.
Ich musste
einen Businessplan schreiben
und einen Investoren und Partner
finden, verstehst du?
Es ist ... Wir hätten auch
einen kleinen Keller nehmen
und sagen können:
"Komm, wir fangen mit zehn PCs an."
Aber wenn du es machst,
dann richtig.
Und es ist ...
Mit dem Geld, das hier investiert
wurde, kannst du zwei Häuser bauen.
Guten Tag,
Martina Alex ist mein Name.
Frau Götsch, ja?
Herr Götsch.
Entschuldigung, Herr Götsch.
Martina Alex ist mein Name. Grüezi.
Herr Götsch ...
Ich verkaufe ja gar nichts.
Herr Götsch, es geht
um eine unverbindliche Broschüre.
Um Informationsmaterial.
Herr Götsch,
Sie wissen nicht, worum es geht.
Noch nicht.
Es dauert nur eine Minute.
Ich will Ihnen gar nichts verkaufen.
Ich bedanke mich, tschüss.
Wir sind fertig.
Tschüss.
* Sie sprechen albanisch. *
Ich feiere den sehr.
Ich finde dieses Lied so geil!
* Sanftes Poplied:
"Amerika" von Adrian Stern *
# Du häsch mer letschti gseit,
# es fehl dr öppis da.
# Heigsch s'Gfühl
du blibisch schtoh.
# Chum, mir haued ab.
# Chum, mir fönd neu a.
# Chum, mir stieged in es Flugzüg
und verschwinded uf Amerika.
# Chum, mir boued es Huus.
- So kann die Welt sein.
Er will nach Amerika und
ich wieder zurück in die Schweiz.
Jetzt zeige ich dir alles,
was mein Sohn bekommt. Schau mal.
Er liebt Spider-Man.
Ich habe ihm einen Rucksack gekauft.
Das Polizeiauto darf nicht fehlen.
Ich weiss nicht, von wem er das hat,
aber er ist ein Polizeifan.
Er liebt die Polizei.
Schau mal,
was ich ihm noch gekauft habe.
(Lautsprecher) # Whoa, I feel good.
# I knew that I would, now.
- Er wird sich totlachen.
# I feel good.
# I knew that I would.
# So good.
# So good, I got you.
Hat er keinen Stecker?
# Whoa!
* Fröhliche Funkmusik *
Okay.
Er muss doch irgendwo einen ...
# When I hold you in my arms,
# I know that I can't do no wrong.
- Ist gut, du kannst aufhören.
# When I hold you in my arms ...
* Die Musik stellt ab. *
Zweimal in zwei Wochen
haben wir geskypt.
Ich bin froh, dass seine Mutter
diesbezüglich nicht bockig tat.
Er hat eine gute Mami.
Und heute sagte seine Mami,
dass wir zusammen den Weihnachtsbaum
schmücken könnten.
Darauf freue ich mich mega.
Megacool.
* Melancholische Musik *
Nach über einem Jahr im Kosovo
ist es so weit.
Du hast ein Spezialvisum gekriegt
und darfst für zwölf Tage
zurück in deine Heimat.
Wichtig ist mir einfach, dass er ...
... dass er mich erkennt.
Dass er sieht, dass sein Papi
nicht für immer weg ist.
Vielleicht, weil ...
Wie willst du
einem knapp Dreijährigen erklären,
dass sein Vater ein paar Tage da ist
und dann wieder gehen muss?
Meine Heimat.
(Lautsprecher)
Herzlich willkommen in Zürich.
Wir bitten Sie,
angeschnallt sitzen zu bleiben,
bis wir
unseren Standplatz erreicht haben
und das Anschnallzeichen
ausgeschaltet ist.
Es ist ja alles
vor seiner Geburt passiert.
Ich muss mir nicht vorwerfen,
dass ich ... äh ...
... einen falschen Weg
eingeschlagen hatte,
obwohl ich einen Sohn hatte.
Das nicht.
Er wurde
erst nach meinen Taten geboren.
Erst dann erkannte ich,
was es heisst, Vater zu sein.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ja.
Ich bin im Moment meganervös.
Ich sehe meinen Kleinen in 50 Min.
Ähm ...
Ich besuche ihn und weiss nicht,
wie er auf mich reagieren wird.
Jetzt mittlerweile ...
Zwei Jahre hat er mich ...
Nicht mal.
Eineinhalb Jahre
hat er mich live kennengelernt
und 15 Monate jetzt nur per Telefon.
Und ... äh ... ich bin gespannt,
wie er reagieren wird.
Ob er mich noch erkennt.
Und wie er es auffassen wird.
Ich bin total nervös. Ich war schon
megalange nicht mehr so nervös.
* Melancholische Musik *
Hm!
Jetzt wird es Zeit zu gehen.
Ich freue mich einerseits.
Andererseits habe ich mega Angst.
Aber ich denke, wir haben eine gute
Beziehung zueinander ... gehabt.
Wir versuchen, sie weiterhin
so zu pflegen, auch per Telefon,
obwohl es sehr schwierig ist.
Ein Sohn braucht seinen Vater.
* Melancholische Musik *
Dein Wiedersehen mit deinem Sohn
durfte ich nicht filmen.
Ich fragte dich mehrmals,
wie es mit deinem Sohn war -
wie es für dich war, wie es dir geht.
Du wichst meinen Fragen aus
und warst sehr still.
Du kamst mir gehetzt vor -
wie jemand auf der Flucht.
Und du sprachst in Rätseln.
Nachdem du zurück
in den Kosovo geflogen warst,
hörte ich
wieder nichts mehr von dir.
Ich machte mir Sorgen.
Gleichzeitig war ich irritiert,
weil du nicht
auf meine Nachrichten reagiertest.
Erst nach eineinhalb Jahren
höre ich wieder von dir.
Jemand erzählte mir, dass du
ein weiteres Spezialvisum bekamst
und während dieser Zeit eine
Postfiliale in Dübendorf überfielst.
Du wurdest rückfällig.
Und wieder
holte die Kriminalität dich ein.
Es dauerte nicht lange
und ich begann, mich zu fragen,
warum du das getan hast. Warum?
Du hättest nur noch knapp zwei
Jahre im Kosovo durchhalten müssen.
Ähm ...
Es begann ...
... damit, dass die Tür aufging.
Zwei, drei Leute kamen herein.
Sie sagten: "Hallo! Woher kommst du?
Was machst du? Was macht ihr hier?"
Ich dachte, es seien Interessenten,
die sich
fürs Callcenter interessieren.
Es kamen immer wieder Leute,
die fragten oder einen Job suchten.
Dann erzählte ich, was wir machen.
Dann sagten sie: "Ja,
du brauchst sicher unseren Schutz."
Dann fiel mir der Jeton runter.
Ich fing an zu lachen und sagte:
"Ihr könnt hier
einen Kaffee trinken."
"Ihr könnt gerne noch bleiben
und euch alles ansehen."
"Dann könnt ihr gehen
und müsst nicht wiederkommen."
"Ich komme
aus einer anderen Welt als ihr."
Ich lernte dort im Kosovo
einen Polizisten kennen.
Seine Nichte arbeitete bei mir.
Ich ging zu ihm ins Büro
und sagte ihm, was los war.
Dass solche Leute kommen und ...
Ich musste
nicht mal deren Auto erwähnen.
Der Polizist wusste schon,
um wen es ging.
Ich fragte ihn:
"Was kann ich machen?"
"Ich möchte nicht
gerade Anzeige erstatten, aber ..."
"Ich möchte einfach
in Ruhe weiterarbeiten."
Dann sagt mir der Polizist, dass sie
denen gegenüber machtlos sind.
Es kam zu einem Treffen.
Mir wurde wieder gedroht.
Ich habe auch gedroht.
Solange es mit Wörtern geschieht,
ist eigentlich alles gut.
Dann fiel ein Satz,
der nicht hätte fallen müssen.
Und dann sah ich rot. Ich ging
auf den einen von ihnen los.
Es kam zu einer Schlägerei.
Für mich ging sie gut aus,
für die nicht.
Ich ging in Richtung Markt.
Ich musste etwas holen.
Dann kamen die beiden Autos.
Sie kamen aus zwei Querstrassen.
Das eine kam von dieser Seite,
das andere von der anderen.
Das weisse Auto fuhr nach links,
das schwarze nach rechts.
Dann wurde das Fenster geöffnet
und geschossen.
Mein Glück war,
dass ich hinter einem Container war.
Ich versteckte mich
hinter dem Container,
zog meine eigene Waffe
und schoss zurück. Ähm ...
Ich kann es nicht sagen, weil man
in dem Moment Adrenalin hat.
Ich hatte noch nie
auf jemanden geschossen.
Aber ich glaube,
mich erinnern zu können,
dass ich eher in Richtung Luft
schoss. Nicht direkt auf die.
Bei uns regieren
immer noch die Dorfältesten.
Das ist so das Alte Testament
oder wie auch immer man das nennt.
Keine Ahnung. Die Dorfältesten
hören sich beide Versionen an
und setzen dann etwas fest.
Bei mir war es so,
dass ich Geld hätte bezahlen
und den Kosovo für zwei Jahre
hätte verlassen müssen.
Damit diese ihre Macht
wieder repräsentieren können.
Also damit sie sagen können:
"Okay, jetzt
hat einer Widerstand geleistet,
aber wir sind so mächtig, dass
dieser Mensch nicht mehr da ist
und Geld bezahlt hat."
Eines führte zum anderen und ...
* Stimmengewirr *
Noch schnell vorbei.
So.
Und dann in diese Richtung blicken?
Nein, eher dorthin, oder?
- Sie können auch zu mir blicken.
Was jetzt?
- Blicken Sie zu ihm.
In diese Richtung?- Einfach zu mir,
nicht in die Kamera.
Kommst du durch?
- Ja.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft ist
mit dem heutigen Urteil zufrieden.
Das Bezirksgericht Uster
ist in rechtlicher Hinsicht
der rechtlichen Würdigung
der Staatsanwaltschaft gefolgt.
Was das Strafmass anbelangt,
haben wir 57 Monate beantragt.
51 Monate ist die Verurteilung.
Damit sind wir zufrieden.
Was den Landesverweis anbelangt,
sind wir fünf Jahre tiefer.
Wir müssen dann prüfen,
sobald wir die rechtliche Würdigung,
die Begründung fürs Urteil
erhalten haben,
ob wir in Berufung gehen oder nicht.
Haben Sie ihm
die Geschichte abgenommen,
dass er im Kosovo verfolgt wurde
oder dort Probleme hatte?
Wir haben versucht, zusammen
mit der Kantonspolizei Zürich
diese Geschichte zu verifizieren.
Wir hatten weder Anhaltspunkte
dafür, dass sie stimmt,
noch dafür, dass sie nicht stimmt.
Darum gingen wir nicht darauf ein.
Es ist schon krass, oder?
Ich habe mir das
damals tätowieren lassen.
Und auch den kleinen Schatten
meines Sohnes. Siehst du?
Und dieser kleine Schatten
soll mich daran erinnern,
keinen Scheiss mehr zu machen.
Von einer Zelle aus
sich selber im Spiegel zu sehen.
Zu versuchen,
sich etwas zu vergrössern.
Und jetzt sehe ich ihn hier
ganz alleine auf dem Boden.
Scheissdreck!
Die Schweiz ist nicht schuld,
dass ich hier bin. Das bin ich.
Ich habe entschieden,
das zu machen.
Und ich bin wieder hier drin.
Ich trage die Verantwortung dafür.
Aber ...
Man macht eine Therapie.
Man bekommt die Möglichkeit,
eine Lehre zu machen.
Man kämpft so stark und erreicht
so vieles, wie ich das getan habe.
Ich habe gezeigt,
dass sich Menschen ändern können.
Und dann kriegt man
den Schuh in den Arsch.
Es heisst: "Gehe!"
Wohin? Wohin soll ich gehen?
Herkunftsland.
"Sie sind selber schuld,
dass Sie keinen Schweizer Pass
beantragt haben",
muss ich mir anhören.
"Selber schuld,
dass du keinen Schweizer Pass hast."
Mit acht, neun Jahren hätte ich
natürlich zur Scheissgemeinde gehen
und sagen sollen: "Ich möchte
übrigens Schweizer werden."
Ich glaube, das muss
automatisch kommen, oder nicht?
Ja.
Wie fühlst du dich,
wenn du an die Zukunft denkst?
Wie ich mich fühle? Hm ...
Ich glaube, wenn ich mir Mühe gebe,
werde ich es schon schaffen,
mir meinen Wunsch ... Wie sagt man?
Meinen Wunsch ...
- ... zu erfüllen.
Ja. Aber eben: Man braucht auch ...
Man muss daran arbeiten.
Ich finde, man sollte
auch nicht so schnell aufgeben.
Sonst ist eigentlich ...
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022